[Music]
we are a rumor recognizable only as deja
vu and dismissed just as quickly
we are the best-kept secret in the
universe I know I want in you erase my
parents memories that you didn't get
mine took me 20 years to find you how
many people can say that I found you
which makes me perfect for this job
[Music]
how did you
you will be with Asian Paints MIB you
Karelian scum and fYI your little Club
here sucks
come on world's not gonna save itself
I'm driving that really should be here
Joey I thought that we were here wait
are you a queen indeed she is I pledged
loyalty eternal to you no no I'm not
interested too late I already pledged
the loyalty I wish you'd said no no no
before we've never faced a threat like
the hive they can take the form but
anyone I haven't seen that before
our own agents do we have a plan
sometimes you have to trust your gut
men and black has been compromised on
trust that means everyone and everything
on we are the men in black the men and
women in black yeah perfectly done
are you suggesting that we try the most
powerful weapon in the galaxy for fun do
it
turn it up as you
[Music]